Maxence Nour bonjour bonjour Véronique
merci de nous accueillir ici nous sommes
dans la cour des senteurs
nous sommes devant la boutique Guerlin
que vous dirigez et la seule d'ailleurs
boutique Guerlin hors de Paris
exactement c'est une boutique très
importante pour nous pour gerlin parce
que c'est la première en dehors de Paris
toutes les boutiques gerlin qui
présentent toutes les collections sont
vraiment à l'intérieur de Paris Paris
intramuros et vous êtes venu avec
d'autres d'autres artisans de luxe si on
peut dire puisque nous avons aussi
diptique la maison Fabre les gantiers et
la maison le nôre voà ex pour former
cette cour des senteurs qui est une
sorte d'écran de luxe exactement et
c'est un concept c'est un concept autour
des saveurs et des senteurs donc
vraiment le but c'était de trouver un
lien commun entre ces quatre maisons et
il y en a un puisqueeffectivement les
gantiers au 17e siècle étai ceux qui
commercialisaient le parfum le métier de
gantier parfumeur ils avaient eux seuls
le droit de commercialiser les parfums
donc il y a un lien les bougies
liptiques les bougies ont marqué
l'histoire du château et à Versailles
notamment et puis Garlin c'est un
parfumeur et on s'est associé aussi avec
le nôre pour les saveurs puisquon va le
voir même tout à l'heure saveur Center
c'est très lié en parfumerie à savoir le
fronton de cette magnifique boutique
qu'est-ce qu'on voit alors il y a une
histoire en fait sur cette boutique
c'est que c'est une boutique vraiment
atypique on a fait appel à des artistes
et des artisan pourquoi parce qu'on est
dans un quartier d'artisanat et ce
depuis le 17e siècle et du coup on a
voulu faire appel pour montrer le
savoir-fire français mais à la fois sur
le notre métier notre cœur de métier qui
est la parfumerie mais aussi on a fait
appel à ceux qu' ont pu nous aider dans
l'architecture de cette boutique alors
un premier clin d'œil à Versailles avec
Vénus Vénus en fait c'est la
reproduction du mascaron que nous avons
sur le 68 Champs-Élysée qui est notre
boutique principale et en fait Vénus on
est quand même attaché à nos racines
donc on va parler beaucoup de nos
racines de nos ailes et Vénus elle
regarde vers Paris vers nos racines et
Vénus c'est aussi un petit clin d'œil au
au château et au jardin puisque Vénus
dans la mythologie elle s'est piqué le
dot avec une rose et c'est son sang
colorer les roses ah ça vient de là ça
vient de là d'accord et en fait
l'organisation de la boutique va se
faire avec cette Vénus qui est sans
couleur pour vous inviter à découvrir la
couleur qui est tout au bout de la
boutique alors on y va on part pour la
couleur donc Maxence nous voici dans la
première partie de la boutique
Guerlin nous avons quelques objets d'art
contemporains on commence par quoi vous
êtes accueilli par un lustre et ça c'est
un petit lien avec le château encore
évidemment le château de Versailles est
très influent sur la ville et il
organise en fait la ville architecturale
en partant de la chambre du roi on a des
allées et des avenues et on s'est dit
euh on va implanter un lustre mais c'est
pas n'importe quel lustre puisque c'est
la reproduction d'un lustre réalisé par
une artiste contemporaine qui s'appelle
mariechristophe et mariechristophe elle
travaille ce qu'on appelle en art
contemporain l'Inside out donc en fait
elle a pris un lustre qui était descendu
pendant les soirées d'appartement de
elle l'a fait à l'envers c'estàd qu'elle
a mis le cristal à l'intérieur du fer
elle mis la lumière à l'intérieur du
lustre notamment à l'endroit où on
mettait les pommandiers pour parfumer
les pièces vous mettait les quoi les
pomandiers les pomandiers c'était des
des boîtes ouvragées en fer qui se
refermaient dans lesquel on mettait des
concrètes de parfum pour parfumer les
pièces des concrètes de parfum qu'est-ce
que c'est donc la concrète de parfum
c'est en fait une association de
matières premières qui ont été très
concentrées et qui sont mises de manière
solide et ce sont des matières solides
parfumées qui parfumer les pièces bon
donc ça c'est le donc voilà pour le pour
le lustre après là il y a quelque chose
de magnifique quelque chose de
magnifique et qui est vraiment un clin
d'œil là notre histoire Garlin aussi on
a recherché dans nos archives un symbole
de l'astre solaire on est encore à
versaill et c'était un symbole de nos
savons sapochetti en 1830 donc c'est un
petit clin d'œil historique ça tombait
bien parce qu' effffectivement à
Versailles il faut savoir que c'est
aussi quelque chose qui a été réalisé
par un artiste contemporain qui
s'appelle Pierre luouis dci qui est
sculpteur et qui a réalisé cette
reproduction du du symbole gerlin desès
1830 donc c'est un clin d'œil à
l'histoire et justement à ces avenues
dont je vous parlais qui partent de la
chambre comme des rayons de soleil pour
éclairer le peuple c'était le roi qui
éclairait le peuple et nous comme nous
sommes sur une de ces avenus on a décidé
de de se mettre et vous accueillir sous
les rayons du soleil parfait et de notre
astre ok donc porté par ces rayons du
soleil nous allons pouvoir apercevoir
ici des fabuleux flacons qui m'ont l'air
d'époque alors ce sont des flacons
évidemment originaux qu'on expose dans
cette partie de la boutique qu'on
appelle l'atelier et vous avez vraiment
des parfums assez exceptionnels des des
vous avez des parfums du du début du 20e
siècle alors voilette pardon voilette de
Madame 1904 alors le parfum est
exceptionnel mais le contenant aussi là
on voit une forme escargot là on voit un
bouchon qui d'ailleurs n'a rien
d'exceptionnel pour moi mais St en
historiquement il est exceptionnel parce
que le F dat qu' date de 1846 et on est
sur une autre toilette et l'utre
toilette à l'époque c'est une autre
friction c'est-à-dire que on se
frictionnait le corps comme Louis XIV le
faisait d'accord il était frictionné
avec de l'eau de vinaigre là c'était des
eau qui ressemblaient un petit peu plus
à des colognes qui étaient très
alcoolisé et c'était vraiment de de
friction parce que le parfum n'était
c'était réservé par de l'hygièneors ça
faisait partie de l'hygiène et c'était
vraiment un moyen de se laver ensuite là
on aperçoit un autre célèbre parfum
après londé alors après londé qui a un
petit lien quand même avec Versailles
puisqu'on est sur un flacon qui est
vraiment dans le style louis 16 et le
capuchon en fait le cabochon de ce de ce
flacon a la forme d'un uillet qui était
une des fleurs préférées de
Marie-Antoinette donc c'est un petit
hommage à préander c'est ça le lien bien
OK et là on aperçoit une magnifique
boiserie ça pourrait être de l'ében mais
c'est du bois de chaîne en fait
teintéinté d'accord et on est très fier
parce que c'est la maison FeO qui les a
réalisé pour nous ils sont réputé être
parmi les meilleurs du monde en terme de
boiserie et ils travaillent depuis euh
de très très nombreuses années voir
plusieurs siècles et ils ont travailler
pour nous sur des symboles Garlins et
notamment ce qu'on appelle chez nous la
gumininade ont inséré voilà Inade alors
déjà on va expliquer alors la garlinade
ça correspond la garlinade c'est
vraiment une signature olfactive Garlin
on est une des rares maisons avoir une
telle signature c'estd que quand on sent
un parfum Garlin on se dit tiens c'est
un Garlin on reconnait et ça c'est lié à
des matières premières des notes parce
que une matière première c'est une note
dans un parfum et il y a six notes qu'on
retrouve toujours plus ou moins dosé en
tout tout parti il y a toujours des
éléments de la gmininade chez gmin alors
on y va en fait en regardant les
voiseries vous avez la f tonka
vous avez la vanille vous avez le jasmin
vous avez l'iris vous avez la rose et
vous avez la bergamote et c'est quoi
pardon la petite boule alors cette
petite boule c'est la fève tonkain non
je parlais de celle-là alors ça ce sont
des fruits rouges on a
aussi pas parl chez Garin ça fait pas
partie de la garlinade mais on a des
parfums de plus en plus gourmands très
bien vous êtes en train d'évoluer
exactement changer un peu votre ligne
olfactive ou on la change pas disons qu'
on essaie aussi de faire rentrer des
génération nouvelle dans nos boutiques
c'est le cas de la petite robe noire par
exemple la petite robe noire c'est un
parfum gourmand d'où cette note de
framboise d'accord qu'on trouve dans la
petite Rob noire couture qui vient
d'être créée justement avec une base de
framboise d'accord et qui correspond à
un public assez jeune alors il y a de
tout il y a de tout il y a pas de règles
en parfumerie en fait on a
aussi des femmes de 80 ans qui adorent
la peti r noir couture et qu'il porte
mais on a des jeunes aussi qu'il aiment
beaucoup ok voilà donc là maintenant
nous sommes sous le regard de Thierry
vesser qui est l'actuel né de Guerlin
c'est notre parfumeur exclusif
effectivement voilà qui a travaillé pour
cette boutique exclusive en créant un
parfum ou une a toilette vous allez nous
le dire qui s'appelle une a toilette qui
s'appelle cours des centeurs versaill
cours des centeurs versaill alors on
s'est vraiment inspiré d'un flacon
ancien on parle toujours de nos racines
et de nosal on aime bien cette
expression chez Garin nos racines c'est
ce flacon de 1853 sur lequel on voit des
sur lequel on voit des abeilles alors il
a une petite histoire que je peux vous
raconter très rapidement ou
1853 Napoléon I va épouser la princesse
Eugénie elle est espagnole lui est
français et il commande un flacon à
consonance militaire d'où la forme qui
est en fait la forme alors celui-ci je
peux vous le ramené il est un peu lourd
mais voilà voilà le flacon magnifique le
fameux flacon à Ba qui est très
important chez gerlin et ce flacon il y
a des abeilles l'abeille c'est
l'asscendance de Napoléon I Napoléon 1er
évidemment donc c'est le le côté
impérial ensuite vous avez le nombre
d'abeilles qui est le nombre de
provinces de l'époque et puis vous avez
la forme la forme c'est le haut de la
colonne vandô pourquoi parce que la
colonne vandome elle a été fondue avec
les canons d'ostergass alors ce flacon
le réutilise et on a ajouté un nœu rouge
en hommage à Louis XIV et à ces fameux
talons rouges que lui seul et son frère
s'ctroyent le droit de porter donc c'est
un signe de noblesse qu'on retrouve dans
d'autres mararques hein sur certaines s
certaines chaussures il y a des talons
rouges ça vient aussi de de de là on y
retrouve l'astre qu'on a vu à l'entré la
boutique et surtout le parfum qui a
utilisé c'est celui du jasmin pourquoi
parce que le jasmin c'est vraiment la
fleur royale qu'on mettait dans les
allées pour parfumer le bas des robes
des dames de la cour et on est vraiment
sur un parfum qu'aurait pu apprécier
marieanttoinette par exemple et le
jasmin qu'on utilise c'est un jasmin
très rare qui un jasmin de Calabre et
qui est apparemment très proche de celui
qu'on avait au 17e et 18e siècle bon on
va continuer notre petite visite avec
plaisir et vers l'art contemporain plis
voilà on s'approche du du Pr
présent nous voici maintenant dans
l'autre partie de la boutique voilà on
est donc dans le présent le contemporain
si je puis dire voilà c'est la partie
maquillage de la boutique voilà oui on
est plus dans les flacons là on est dans
le maquillage on est dans le maquillage
on est tout au fond on est dans la
couleur dans la couleur et on est dans
l'explosion solaire en fait alors c'est
Nicolas Dolce Nicolas Dolce c'est un
artiste contemporain qui est fasciné par
le travail de Jackson Pollock et Jackson
Pollock il travaille en dripping
c'està-dire qu'il prenait des des
pinceaux et il faisait tomber de la
couleur comme ça par terre et sur ces
toiles et là c'est travaillé en
projection je parlais des artistes des
artisan c'est un artiste contemporain
qui est de renommée internationale qui
s'associe à des maîtres verriers pour
réaliser ce support en verre il y a 8 m
de portée donc c'est un travail assez
titanesque en terme de verrerie et il a
représenté une explosion solaire donc il
a appelé son œuvre Big Bang explosion
solaire en hommage à Lou XIV à l'astre
qu'on a vu à l'entrée de la boutique et
ensuite vous avez cet astre qui en fait
va exploser pour donner de la lumière
c'est la création en fait c'est
l'origine du monde donc la création ça
reprend en plus nos couur nos couleurs
de de maquillage et ensuite on va
jusqu'au bleu et le bleu c'est l'eau la
vie et la vie c'est notre gamme de soins
et comme notre gamme de soin est à base
d'orchidée on l'a représenté aussi sur
un sur une boiserie qui elle est
contemporaine avec des racines
d'orchidées qui sont sculptées et qui
sont sculpté un petit peu comme des
plumes donc ça donne la le côté texture
de nos de nos produits aussi texture
légère exactement oh comme je comprends
bien dites-moi la maison Guerlin enfin
la boutique Guerlin versail propose
justement là vous êtes une un puit de
science vous envie d'en savoir plus
justement c'est possible parce que vous
proposez différents ateliers auxquels on
s'inscrit oui et qui ont différents
thèmes voilà qui permettent
d'approfondir un peu nos connaissances
en terme de parfum d'histoire et cetera
donc quels sont-ils ces ces ateliers
alors étant ayant près de de siècles
d'histoire on propose un atelier qu'on
appelle petit- dééjeuner visite autour
d'un petit- déjeuner dans la partie
atelier on va vous expliquer l'histoire
de cette boutique ce qu'on a vu un petit
peu et aussi l'histoire de Guerlin de la
maison Guerlin en 1828 voilà donc c'est
vraiment accès patrimoine il y a un
deuxième type d'atelier où en plus du
patrimoine on va ajouter l'art des
matières premières qu'est-ce que l'art
des matières premières qu'est-ce qu'une
rose quels sont les différents types de
roses et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
Garlin parfumeur CR et il y a un
troisième type où là il est accessible
pour des enfants sous le nom de
petitgerlin et sous le nom de
comptearfumé pour les adultes ou en plus
du patrimoine on va vraiment vous parler
de l'art des matières premières mais
aussi du métier du parfumeur donc
qu'est-ce qu'une note qu'est-ce qu'un
accord et en plus vous allez avoir une
partie création puisquon va vous
proposer de créer votre propre parfum en
faisant des
essaisation la CR dans le même atelier
on a l'initiation à la création donc on
peut se dire tiens j'ai envie de de
créer mon parfum ou à la recherche de
mon parfum perdu en il y a plein de
choses possibles alors voilà les notes
qu'on aime mettre dans un parfum des
notes qu'on apprécie et c'est vraiment
une excellente initiation ok ben écoutez
ça donne très envie et déjà merci pour
cet aperçu alléchant et à très vite vous
êtes chez vous au revoir d'accord
merci